dear colleagues good afternoon can I ask
you to take your
seats good
[Music]
afternoon dear colleague
please take your
seats we
have today this afternoon with
us Goodwill Ambassador for the United
Nations Refugee agency Kate Blanchett
welcome to the European
[Applause]
Parliament
Kate Blanchett has been a dedicated
activist on humanitarian issues for
years we know her for her activism as
well as for her work in film we are
delighted that you are able to be here
with us today at at a time when events
around the world threaten more lives and
force more people to
flee almost 80 years ago you stated that
there has never been a more crucial time
to stand with refugees and show
solidarity
sadly children and Men since I am proud
that this institution has led the debate
on a European level to find a way
forward that tackles this challenge of
Our Generation and I am hopeful that we
will agree on a new Asylum and migration
pact for Europe by the end of this
legislature this parliament's commitment
to these challenges remains unwavering
for all those who lost their lives for
all the exploited victims of traffickers
for all those families never to be
reunited we remember them and Miss
Blanchet we are grateful to you for
using your voice to draw greater
attention to the plight of so many
people across the world the floor is
[Applause]
[Music]
yours Madame President honorable members
MERS of the European Parliament thank
you for the opportunity of addressing
the parliament today at such a critical
moment it is a great though somewhat
daunting
privilege I am not Syrian I am not
Ukrainian I am not yemeni I am not
Afghani I am not from South Sudan I am
not from Israel or
palestin I am not a politician I am not
even a
pundit but I am a
witness and having witnessed the human
cost of War violence and persecution
visiting refugees from across the globe
I cannot Look
Away what sits at the core of my dual
roles as actor and Goodwill Ambassador
for unhcr is The Human Condition the
human
story and over the past few weeks we
have all in horror been watching the
continuing violence in Israel and Gaza
the conflict has claimed and is still
claiming thousands of innocent lives
earlier this week unhcr's High
Commissioner called together with
several other humanitarian organizations
for an immediate humanitarian ceasefire
and the immediate
release of all civilians held
[Music]
hostage alas while these events are
understandably dominating the news this
is far from the only violence afflicting
our world and these are not the only
innocent lives being
lost War rages on in Ukraine it rages in
Sudan where it's already forced millions
of people to flee their homes since
erupting earlier this year indeed in
recent times the headlines have brought
us news of violence in Ethiopia or
Afghanistan in the Sahel and many others
and in every single case innocent people
suffer and innocent people are forced to
run for their
lives globally forc displacement has now
passed the Grim Milestone of
114 million
people many of those caught up in these
maelstroms have made unbelievably
dangerous Journeys in search of a place
of
safety on arrival too many of them have
found themselves unwanted rejected
despised even scapegoat million people
it's a number so huge that it is
difficult to grasp but grasp it we must
as we acknowledge the figures and the
facts because the fact is of those 114
million
62.5 million are displaced internally
within their own countries and of the
others 36.4 million who are forced to
leave their countries 69% of them remain
in neighboring countries places that I
have had the great privilege of visiting
such as Bangladesh South Sudan Jordan
ner and
Lebanon why do people stay so close to
these places because just as I just as
we would if we were in their
shoes they want to return home
to their people to their land to their
families I urge each and every one of
you here today to stand firm in
challenging the dangerous myth pedal far
too widely and stoking far too much fear
and hostility that each and every
Refugee is headed here to
Europe it has been tempting for some in
Europe to depict the challenge of
refugees as a new one the 1951 Refugee
convention they say is from another time
it was not designed to meet the
challenge of so many people pograms
persecution over the centuries many were
refused Asylum or if they were admitted
they were admitted under sufferance and
regarded with
suspicion but many were welcomed not
just sheltered but actively encouraged
to contribute to the social cultural and
economic life of the lands they now call
home free to practice their religion
provided with livestock tools and seeds
granted citizenship and gradually
beneficially absorbed into the societies
who embraced
them this mixed picture is recognizable
in Europe
today in some cases we immediately see
that fleeing home leaving everything
behind and having to run for one's life
is unavoidable we instinctively feel the
need and obligation to help in others
perhaps because we know little of the
violence or human rights abuses that
take place far from here we are
suspicious and so vulnerable people are
caught between a place from which they
were forced to flee through no fault of
their own and a placed ineffective and
inhumane policies
Madam president in my capacity as
Goodwill Ambassador I have had the
enormous privilege of traveling to meet
refugees in countries across the world
and there are so many humbling things
that I have witnessed and learned from
the people who have generously shared
their stories with me but here are just
three first the refugees that I have met
are in a State of shock shock at what
they have seen and experienced shock at
finding themselves uprooted shock at
losing everything and having to start
again from
scratch but this is not just about the
most vulnerable the women threatened not
only by bombs and bullets but by
unimaginable intolerable sexual abuse
and the children who have lost their
Futures as well as their homes it is
also about the young men who are so
often demonized in the media but who are
visibly traumatized by the physical
abuse and humiliation that they have
endured I recently yet met a young man
let's call him Ibrahim in niir he was a
refugee from Dar for for son alone and
deeply traumatized he had tried to take
a boat to Europe not once but seven
times he told me he took his chances
because drowning at Sea was a better
option than his catastrophic experiences
in Africa in the words of the poet wson
CH no one leaves
home
to escape that mouth of the
shark and in the decades since many more
have perished in the same way and in 10
years time people will still be drowning
on our Shores unless something
changes complex situations require
complex Solutions they require dialogue
they require collaboration not sound
bites or slogans finding Sustainable
Solutions in countries of origin Transit
and
Des terrible violence they would much
prefer to stay as close to home as
possible think back to that fact 69% of
refugees stay in a country neighboring
their own and I have witnessed
remarkable generosity on the part of
some of the neighboring countries who
have kept their borders open to refugees
when in Jordan this year I visited alah
a Syrian refugee I had first met in
2016 she was benefiting from a Daffy
scholarship which enabled her to access
tertiary education 8 months pregnant
together they were building livelihoods
and building community and a peaceful
coexistence their children were going to
school together not one of these people
was contemp lating stealing someone's
livelihood subverting anyone's values
imposing on anyone's Hospitality or
demanding charity ibraim Miriam Allah
and the women I met in nier Wanted only
opportunity kindness compassion and
peace the third
lesson I'd like to share has been a
particularly tough one to take I have
seen the impact of humanitarian funding
cuts on the ground the terrible choice
in US Dollars before the end of the year
and being short of resources the High
Commissioner wondered for how much
longer humanitarians
can are tough he said but humanitarians
are near breaking point and what will
you be left with when they are forced to
go in South Sudan this July I saw that
Dev devastating impact of insufficient
funding as refugees and returnees poured
out of Sudan a lack of shelter a lack of
food or protection support for
vulnerable women standing in mud barely
enough water I ask you how can people
stay Madam president I am not denying
that this is complex but this is the
European Union and addressing the
challenges of force displacement and
movements requires Unity International
cooperation resources and patient
compassionate work to address the
multiple and overlapping reasons that
people
move so my plea to the parliament is
also
three-fold first please remember the
forces that cause people like Ibrahim
and Miriam to move and ensure EU policy
focuses on their protection and not on
fortifying
borders while numbers of forcibly people
of people forced to flee are increasing
globally funding is decreasing the EU
can provide the model for enlightened
leadership Investing For example in
Opportunities and solutions closest to
the countries of departure before people
embark on dangerous
Journeys a clear message out of the most
recent UN General Assembly is if we do
not include refugees in the sustainable
development goals the sdgs themselves
will
fail second as the representatives of
the people of Europe please remind your
constituents that low and middle inome
countries host the vast majority nearly
90% of all forcibly displaced people
take this message to them challenge
false claims that will ultimately only
see divisions in our own communities
scapegoating so so often leads to
violence and unrest and where
coordinated responses to mixed movements
to into Europe are required explain the
importance of safe legal Pathways and
invest in more efficient systems to
quickly humanely and fairly determine
who legitimately has a right to stay and
who does not be robust in defense of the
truth
third
continue continue to build on the eu's
Proud tradition of humanitarian support
whilst also ensuring development funding
goes to host communities and countries
and
refugees agencies like unhcr are often
The Last Resort for desperate people
with a number of forcibly displaced
people at an all-time high flexible
humanitarian funding has never been more
urgent invest in education and
livelihoods to ensure families have
opportunities where they are so they
don't need to move no one will benefit
from a generation of alienated and
excluded young people no one Madam
president on behalf of unhcr May I thank
the European Parliament for its
Progressive role in the European debate
on Asylum and protection may I thank the
parliament the EU and those governments
and organizations and individual
citizens who have have shown such
compassionate leadership in the response
to those forced to flee the war in
Ukraine this solidarity should not be
limited to one group but afforded to
all may I thank the EU for its
long-standing financial support for
refugees and their hosts globally and
urge continued and increased support the
world is
watching May the spirit and hospitality
and compassion and the championing of of
human rights that Europe modeled after
1945 and at the birth of the refugee
convention continue to provide an
Exemplar for years to come thank you
very
[Applause]
much
point